Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is Radiolab and our subject today is cities and if cities are like
organisms, then one thing we should say about every organism that's ever been,
they die. Yeah, they die. So you would think cities would die, you would,
but Jonah says no, cities die very,
very rarely and they almost never die if there hasn't been a total total
catastrophe. Physical catastrophe, which is weird,
you know if you think about it says Jonah cause like take a company and
sometimes it can get very big so that they include hundreds of thousands of
employees and yet they die all the time.
Of the 30 companies in the original Dow Jones,
only three are still in the Dow Jones Index.
If you took 30 cities from the 1920s I can guarantee you all 30 of those
randomly selected cities would still exist on the map. And the question is why?
Why don't they die like every other social organization?
What is it about cities that gives them this crazy persistence?
That question led us to a place the by all measures should have died long ago.
A place called Centralia.
Okay, so we begin on the side of where are we?
We're on route 61 in eastern Pennsylvania. Right. This is bad by the way.
He's a producer at radio lab. I know who pat is. Thank you very much Danielle.
We're waiting for this guy named Tom to meet up with us. Tom.
Tom [inaudible] asked me, are you doing, I'm jet
just now. And we had asked Tom to show us around his town,
probably the best place that goes up on the hill up there and you know,
you could look over everything. Okay,
so we go up on the hill with Tom. We actually meet up with another Tom Dempsey.
I was the former postmaster to Tom's. Tom. Tom, very confusing. Anyhow,
the four of us stare down into a valley that used to have a town in it.
Front of house was all, it was all streets with homes on them all over.
Now Centralia is just trees right down here was the
Tom two point system trees borough high school over here.
No more trees, bedding,
Nike's church are still [inaudible] playground right at the bottom of this
little hill right here. You can still see the bars.
This is where things get a little strange.
I mean right next to the swing set where kids used to laugh their little heads
off. There's a hole in the ground right there.
I can see some steam coming out of the ground spewing steam and that and I would
later discover and we got close to it that that steam is really hot.
It's hot and wet. Oh my God. Huh?
What? Where exactly is the fire underneath this?
Like how far here? 50 feet maybe. So 50 feet down.
If it is cast you, the smell doesn't bother you guys. What smell?
You can smell it. It smells like burning tires here.
That must be from New York. That stuck in your nose. Come on.
It really did smell put the thing. No one can denies that.
Underneath our feet there's a web of coal mines that stretches from miles 40
miles in each direction,
30 miles and somewhere in those mines is a fire that's been burning for 40 years
and has either destroyed this town or not depending on who you ask.
Uh, this is pat right here. My name is Mary Lou Gaughan. I'm ready.
Two years old and I lived in Centralia most of my adult life.
What year were you born in, if you mind me asking, what year was I born? 1927.
Mary Lou gon grew up in a town not too far from Centralia.
Amy Little Farm town called Burnsville.
And when she got to central Iowa she said, well I was like moving to the city.
It had a legion, had a drug store, it had that,
it had a couple thousand people, lots of bars was in center head.
Somebody told me one time they were 22 browns in Centralia.
I don't know if that was true cause I didn't frequent.
Byron's at that age and all these places that you just mentioned were right on
top of each other. So when you were walking around,
you'd see people all the time just take, for instance, you'd go there,
the post office after work where the post office was,
Tommy would be there sometimes. I was postmaster here for a number of years.
Tweet. You're pointing into a forest. It's hard to imagine.
It is hard to imagine and yet I walk to the post office cause your mail wasn't
delivered. So I'd go up to the post office,
I get my mail and you'd meet people in the post office.
You'd meet people coming out of the post office, a good football field here.
It's all growing and nobody's cutting the grass.
There's bushes growing up in it now, Tommy Dempsey, you'd have a story.
I would be an hour till I got home. Whole hour.
This is how Centralia was. Okay. Fast forward,
it's Memorial Day 1962 this is where the borrowers picked up all their garbage.
That if our other store that just about right here where I'm standing right now,
tell me points to a little patch of nondescript yellow grass.
Like why here? How did it start? Do we have any idea? Well,
it started the most likely scenario. He says,
we also heard this from a writer named Joan Quigley,
author of the day the Earth captain is it people used to heat their homes with
coal and maybe somebody threw their ashes into the garbage,
which then ended up onto the dump. They caught the whole thing on fire,
furniture, rugs, kerosene cans, which Joan says wasn't that unusual?
Some of the former firefighters said the dumps caught on fire all the time and
usually the virus just fizzled out on their own. But this one,
for whatever reason before it did wandered a little bit and it found its way
over to an old exposed, exposed Colver in there.
Basically an old strip mine that should have been covered but wasn't so there
was just a big open cavity. When the fire got in there and call the
fire trucks came up here and they hose down to fire. To look out.
It was that and they left following Betty. Somebody says all,
we see smoke and steam coming out of the ground up there.
Came back the next day and they tried to get the fire out and I couldn't very
well do it. They weren't getting it cause at that point it was two legs.
I wouldn't know where to start with this fire. I wouldn't know where to start.
The first place that fire came down was right underneath Mary Lou's house and
from that point on they kind of took over her life like goodness is your
scrapbooks. When we were there,
she pulled out these two gigantic scrapbooks.
It's going to take four men to lift this book.
Each book is literally three feet tall and they document in painful detail how
that fires split the town and to,
this is how intense I was with this mindful fire that she heaved,
opened the book and she showed us this picture of three people crouched on the
street in front of a whole, this is my husband,
my son and me and husband holding a thermometer.
We dropped this down on like a fishing pole down on like you're ice fishing.
Yeah. This is their way of measuring the temperature of the fire and below.
What did they read? It was pretty high. A hundred degrees high.
850 something under your house? No, this was on the street,
but the street right in front of her house and the garage was,
the garage was right as you can see, that garage here, it was right there.
She showed us another picture of her standing in her garage in front of a trench
that they'd dug in inside that trench. You see flames.
We used to go out at night and watch there that, you know,
the glowing and the embers fire up there got so bad that some of Mary Lou's
neighbors actually got government money to leave their houses named where the
first people bought out. Never once, like at the beginning did you think like,
oh, maybe we should just get outta here. No, there's a fire a hundred yards.
You never know. I never went to. Instead, she did exactly the opposite.
My husband, and this was a big official and this was the beginner heals,
started writing letters, men, Nelligan Musto. We wrote letters to him.
We talked on the phone with him.
I couldn't tell you all the congressman we talked the four governors,
all the Harrisburg officials, and they were promising everything but the son.
But it never happened. But other than that, people who lived on that street,
many,
many people in town didn't have to worry or even think about the mind fire.
No one ever believed that the fire was, was even serious in some tried yet.
My husband, myself and Helen Rumor, oh, so everyone else was kind of like,
it's uptown and if fire is uptown, all that changed on Valentine's Day,
1981 we're up a little bit hotter because of this guy.
A fellow named Todd Demboski, who at the time was just a boy.
I was 1212 year old boy. He's playing outside in his grandmother's backyard.
I noticed the small wisps of smoke coming out with the ground.
So he went over to take a look. I was like, I bent down to investigate.
I noticed that my feet were starting to sink in.
It was really soft and it was like quicksand. The more I tried to struggle,
the more, ah,
I was just opening the whole larger and you wound up sliding through my thighs
to my waist until he was,
I was under all the way underground surrounded by hot steam.
Smoke was so intense. Smells like rotten eggs.
While I was screaming for my cousin and his cousin heard him and came running
over, blocked me out like a flower.
What happened to him? Changed everything
because suddenly reporters are everywhere. Reporters from the evening,
Harold's lines, national news media, everybody pointing their cameras at Todd
chief was the mind firing when I did.
I just fell right through and doing stories about this town that was on fire and
he Centralia the underground coal fires still burn.
Hoshan Trillia isn't inferno parts of Centralia look like the outskirts of hell
would focus on what had to happen for the town.
There wasn't long says Joan before. Some of the younger residents, small,
informal group of young parents organized in March,
found locus to have anybody down the main street in town.
How many people are we talking about here?
Couple of dozen with red ribbons around their arms and their wrists and they
walked two by two down the main street of Centralia like striking miners.
Mary Lou glared at them as they passed. I was bitter.
I was bitter with they claim they were for helping the town to be saved,
but they weren't what they were really for. She figured was getting out there,
look for funds to get relocated. She even hated their name,
concerned citizens against the Centralia mine fire. She thought,
how are they the concern citizens, she's the concerned citizen.
She had been fighting the fire for years.
The media was there taking video cameras, film the marchers,
looping red ribbon over everything and Mary Lou's neighbor,
Helen cut the red room and stem because we fought so hard to try to save
Centralia. Why did they want to do this? People like Mary Lou and Helen Willmar.
They started telling people, no, no, no. Here's why it's safe.
Here's why you should say and what parents from the other group were on TV
complaining about gases. It could be a death house. Mary Lou,
Helen and a few others started up their own committee and I didn't.
Centralia area mine task force.
They got on TV themselves and in the community they started printing up flyers,
sac sheets and handing them out door to door. Okay. On a college meeting,
daughter at town meetings,
the dueling committees would get up there and make their case get yelled down,
not protect us. They get rowdy, absolutely ridiculous.
Families fighting against families, neighbors against neighbors.
There's lambing split the town apart. Who's that? David Lamb.
This Guy David Lamb,
ran a motorcycle shop in town and he was also a member of this concerned
citizens organization.
Early morning in one morning at about 4:00 AM he was sleeping in an apartment
and someone threw a Molotov cocktail, threw his plate glass window.
Mary Lou showed us an article from a scrapbook related to lamps activities as an
officer of concerned citizens. Wow, this is no joke.
This is like the Sopranos or worse. This was really,
it was really bad and in the midst of all this chaos,
Congress started considering a bill that would basically let them buy out the
town. Some observers believe that for about $50 million, some truck,
it could be totally bought out until the mayor decided let's hold a referendum
and the issue was stay or go. In the weeks leading up to the referendum,
Mary Lou and Helen again went door to door talking to people.
They'd known their whole lives and pretty much everyone they talked to said,
I really want to stay. My mother wants to stay.
Yeah,
August 11th,
1983 shortly before 10 of the seed banks and he mayor announced the results,
there is 545 votes. Votes cast,
200 voted to stay.
345 voted to relocate. I was crying.
Yes in my heart. I never thought that would happen ever.
You thought that everybody would,
Wednesday maybe 40 people might decide or maybe 30 but that was devastating to
know that so many people wanted to move. It was.
And when you look at her scrapbooks, everything stops after that day. Yeah.
This is just thrown in papers. Wow. It just stopped so abruptly. Yup.
I was always mad and disgusted and I didn't want to,
I didn't want to do it no more about it. That was the end.
Almost immediately after that vote, Congress bought out the town.
People started packing up and leaving. Oh, let me see where it is. I have some,
it has the big numbers that ready. Lou told us that when you decided to leave,
a demolition crew would actually come to your house and paint big red letters
like this.
A big number one in front of your house look like blood was dripping up. Oh,
it's like you were marked. Yeah. And what would happen,
she says when your house was marked is that your neighbors would see it.
They'd get nervous and then suddenly their houses would be marked and then
suddenly the whole block would be marked.
And I knew every one of them quite well and I think I stopped talking to some of
them. She'd see him on the street, she says, and look the other way.
I didn't like any of them really.
And one day in the fall of 1987 these divisions caused something to happen that
is just kind of like mythically bad. Yeah.
It involved a married couple who'd been in the town most.
She'd been there her whole life and as a couple they were divided.
One wanted to stay, one wanted to go.
I think it was the wife I didn't want to leave.
And the husband while he was a shovel runner and he,
he wanted to take the money you get from your location and get out there.
Neighbors were moving,
had moved the houses around them were being torn down and they had to make a
decision and all we really know is that at some point they started to argue and
um, and it escalated.
He stopped her to death with a kitchen knife and then drove up to an old
stripping pit and set himself in his car on fire.
Wow.
Is, this is going to sound like a strange question,
but is there anything about that that makes sense to you?
Like why couldn't people let go of this place?
It is very primal. Beyond that,
she really couldn't say why and we asked Mary Lou who hung on long after the
murder, after that referendum, after the town was basically empty.
I have no idea what kept me there. I have no idea. You have no idea.
No idea. I just didn't want to move the other street
[inaudible] houses down there. Yeah. Now today,
11 people live in town as was better than his wife. Yeah, man.
My mom and them lived down to the intersection.
Tom and Tom pointed them all out from the hill. We knocked on every door,
figured we asked them what it is that keeps them living literally on top of a
fire. Hi, good evening.
Wow. That was the shortest, but none of them wanted to talk to us.
Not even the dogs. Oh, okay. All right.
But then Tom too took us to one last spot.
Where are we right now? You're in San Ignatius, Roman Catholic cemetery.
The cemetery is just a few feet away from the hill where we started.
And it's a really strange contrast.
You go from the steamy hell and then suddenly you're in like,
what's he Vermont? There's a lot of big beautiful, um,
this is my grandfather and my grandmother. Tom has four generations buried here.
Do you know how many people are here? Tom? Odd.
There's over 3000 burials in this cemetery along 3000. Yes.
Plus, and the thing is, as Tom,
even the people that left fled that fire continue to come back and be buried in
this cemetery, which means this place,
the cemetery is the only thing in Centralia that's still growing.
[inaudible]
and suddenly how Joan put it earlier, it is very primal made sense.
You can experience your life on a multigenerational plate.
This is where my great grandparents are buried, which means in a sense,
this town will never die as long as the cemetery is still here.
I don't even read their name on this here. This dig it up. Oh,
it's under the dirt.
Do we get this up by somehow
see
it sinking down into the ground. But it's in the, it's in the dirt. No. Yes, it,
and here we go. We can see a dem has t y s
y thinks about Walters for reporting that with me.
And also to Chris Perkel and Georgie Roland who directed a great documentary
about Centralia called the town that was,
you can find out more information about that on our website.
radiolab.org I'm Robert Krulwich. I'm Jad Abumrad. Bye.